nous sommes tout autant touchée que les
autres régions la situation est
difficile dans l'ensemble des régions
dans la mesure où le ffs est un
établissement unique et nous avons un
maillage territorial qui fait que
l'ensemble des établissements sont
reliés entre eux et en permanence nos
stocks sont équilibrés pour qu'il soit
peu correct en tout cas le plus corrects
possibles
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est à
dire qu'actuellement nous partageons
collectivement la pénurie
le pratiquons à peu près 70 % de notre
collecte en dehors de l'eau mur dans les
communes dans les salles communales dans
les entreprises dans les écoles dans les
universités les salles communales on a
un temps été difficilement accessibles
tout simplement parce qu'elles étaient
réquisitionnés pour réaliser des centres
de vaccination des centres de dépistage
le télétravail c'est très largement
développé dans les entreprises qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui comme ça longtemps des
entreprises qui sont généralement des
entreprises très généreuse eh bien nous
ne retrouvons confrontés à des niveaux
de télétravail extrêmement importants
qui font que le donneur ne sont pas
présents
sur les deux premières semaines du mois
de janvier quarante salariés de
l'établissement renoncer à leurs congés
quarante salariés au renoncer entre un
jour de congé une semaine de congés pour
que tous les jours de la semaine nous
puissions organiser une collecte
supplémentaire
[Musique]